the three divine toys
as i was having a conversation with
felix panara on our show
we were discussing these divine toys
and he mentioned that as the name
for leveraging these in terms of knowing
our true nature and so
now we're going to create a stream
walking through
these different ways to
unite with one's true nature think about
them like different
methods or different strategies or
different lenses
for you to be able to abide in
the true nature
to move yourself more and more often
away from the contracted person identity
and closer and closer upstream towards
the very
source of awareness and realities
the source of infinite creation
and knowing yourself as identity
constituted as that
rather than the person therefore you
begin
serving the creation as a steward as a
shepherd because you know it's all one
intelligence at play with itself rather
than
as the contracted person trying to
extract
from it
all right so the three divine toys
let's start with this is that
what do we mean we mean
this is the absolute
i remember initially watching
tony parsons and jim newman and just
the perpetuation of the idea of
what papaji
and so many others in the neo advice to
tradition
ramana maharshi just saying there's no
steps to freedom
this is already freedom
this is the absolute already
and when i was at the shift into
permanent alignment with bentino massaro
and team in costa rica
i remember talking to him about the
absolute being right here as well
and him saying this is that
right so this is the highest
this is the absolute there's no higher
than this this is the highest
this is the absolute appearing
this is source emptiness nothingness
appearing as one possibility
of a manifestation in the eternal
space of infinite possibility
and so this is an important divine toy
to play with
because it is simply calling people's
attention to the fact that
still your mind enough to recognize
that simply this
present moment right here the entire
universe
the entire civilization you
exactly as you are are perfect all of
life is the absolute all of life is
already freedom
it's a announcement of freedom it's a
manifestation of
absolute freedom
so the first divine toy is this is that
the second divine toy is i make
awareness
and realities i make
awareness and realities
so what we're asking you to do with i
make awareness and realities
is to practice shifting your identity
from being a person
to being the big bang
imagine you are the big bang with a pair
of eyeballs
and you create the manifestation of the
universe
and then now you're seeing your created
manifestation
through these 8 billion units
mind body spirit complexes
humans and you're seeing it from these 8
billion different perspectives
angles
so the entire creation itself appears
within the mind body spirit complex
within the very awareness
so the very personal awarenesses
have their own idea
of what creation is
and then those are all located
on god's jumbotron and that's what's
called the all-inclusive awareness
so the very subject itself
has their own universe
their own interpretation appearing and
disappearing
every single second
and then eight billion
of those
universes appearing and disappearing
every single second on god's jumbotron
we're getting into some of the nuanced
details
of the macro level representation of how
it works but you have to understand that
you are that which gives birth to
god you give birth to the all-inclusive
awareness
that is then
experiencing the creation that you made
so you
have to go to being the very awareness
and reality
that is the source of that
be the very source of the awareness and
reality
be the very big bang shift your identity
to being the very big bang the very
source of the awareness and reality
be the creationary force itself
this divine toy
i make awareness and realities
is also an easy way to become both
nothingness and infinity
so when you say i make awareness and
realities what you say when you say
i is you're referring to the very
emptiness or the very source
that gives birth to the creation itself
it gives birth to infinite creation and
this is one
appearance one manifestation one
representation
one divine player exploration
and then when you say i make awareness
in realities what you're saying is i
make infinite creation so you are both
the very nothingness that manifests
this first attribute of awareness and
all of the realities that it witnesses
become aware that the awareness
itself that you create
is like the first attribute on the
event horizon of the black hole of
source
and that's where we'll also lead to
number three as well the nettie nettie
approach to
source so this number two divine toy
is the i make
awareness and realities and the number
three the nettie nettie the source
is basically starting
in the person and you start in the
person
and the nettie nettie means not this not
that
and you start with this negation process
of okay
i am not a person i'm not my name i'm
not my body i'm not my
thoughts sensations perceptions
okay well what am i then okay i'm the
awareness i'm the subject i'm the very
formless witness
and then that is shared among all humans
okay and then you say i'm not even the
awareness
i'm not even the great inclusive
i am i'm not even god
that's witnessing its own creation at
play with itself
i'm the emptiness the source
that gives rise to the infinite creation
and so when you do this process the
nettie nettie to source what's happening
is
you are negating
the person in order for you to upgrade
your lenses so that you can upgrade from
the person lens
the illusion the contraction to
the lens of awareness and then to the
lens of the source
and then you can more easily navigate
between
the second and third divine toy
because again the third divine toy is
the process of negation
nettie nettie to source so it's from
going what
from what is most downstream
to what is most upstream
just look in your very pupil for the
answer
if you go far enough in your own pupil
you will reach emptiness
and that is the same emptiness in
all human pupils
so the very same first attribute of
awareness is in
all of the human pupils and then if you
transcend
even that all-inclusive awareness across
all
humans that's when you commune with the
very emptiness
in which all arises and all disappears
moment to moment arise the spear rise
the spear arise the spear
sharpie arise disappeared
hand on the forehead or eyes disappear
phone arise disappear
glass of water arise disappear
the very
visual of the glass of water arising
that data coming in source comprehending
that data
and now source no longer comprehends
that data
that's how you can think about it source
comprehending a sharpie and it no longer
comprehending a sharpie
source comprehending a pillow
no longer comprehending a pillow
source comprehending a computer no
longer comprehending a computer
comprehending different things moment to
moment
comprehending different things moment to
moment
comprehending different things moment to
moment
comprehending different things moment to
moment
i love coming up with these little tunes
just source loves coming up with these
through this incarnation it's such a
funny
way of expressing itself
that's what it is comprehending sharpie
moment to moment
gone comprehending pillow moment
to moment gone so
when you begin sort of seeing the very
black
hole source emptiness and the on the
event horizon
is awareness so awareness is the first
attribute on the event horizon of the
black hole of emptiness
that is the intelligent infinity that
creates and comprehends everything
and that when you shift from the person
identity to
awareness you shift to what is more
formless and towards what is more
subtle towards the subject so when you
make that shift you shift from the
physicalism
which does not exist the physicalism is
a dream
even the awareness is a dream but it's
closer to what is real
what is most real is the nothingness or
the emptiness that everything
arises and then disappears into
so the awareness is the first attribute
it's on the event horizon and so if you
get
really really really subtle you can
recognize that there is
both that one god self and even the one
god self
is an intoxicative illusion
so the truth is that there is no self
the truth is that
there is only emptiness dancing
emptiness appearing
this is the absolute and you can take
many different ways to get there
these three divine toys will be helpful
for you
to meditate on take these
concepts these symbols these ideas and
whatever resonates with you
meditate on it use it see it everywhere
you look
everywhere you look on your day-to-day
if the
first divine toy of this is that
resonates then use it when you are
sitting in the sunlight
recognize that you sitting in the
sunlight is the absolute
sitting in the sunlight i am the
absolute sitting in my own sunlight
cool then you're at the grocery store
buying a coconut water
and then you're like i am the absolute
buying a coconut water
from the absolute appearing as a grocery
store that has coconut water for me to
purchase
now as i walk out of the grocery store i
am the absolute drinking
my own creation of coconut water
okay cool you see how simple it is
the first divine toy is literally
telling more and more people that
this is the absolute right now is the
absolute
the very present the eternal present
is the absolute
you are that which creates the
witnessing of infinite creation
so every single this is
the absolute there's no such thing as
not being the absolute
there's no such thing as not being the
absolute
it's always the absolute the only
distortions and delusions that exist
are when a person thinks they are
separate from the absolute
which is the way that the mainstream
indoctrinated nonsensical
matrixy [ __ ] culture baptizes people
and it tells them that the absolute is
separate from you
and then you become a slave in the
corporate economic machinery
and it's our own creation but
liberate yourself from that as soon as
possible
recognize that the whole point of this
distillation and dissemination
is to liberate and awaken the creation
from its delusional intoxicative matrixy
infrastructures
we created those infrastructures as in a
sleeping
mechanism for us to liberate ourselves
from
and to recognize our true nature
everything is always the absolute
and yet it's a big game of identity
your own algorithmic scripted
perpetuation of i am a finite separate
person and i am not the absolute
is a distortion that you are unfreezing
your will and choice and sovereignty to
wake up from
and hopefully content like this helps
so the three divine toys this is that
it's the most simple and easy
and it's very neo advaita it's very
the direct path it's very
mom can get this you know mom
and grandma family
they can get this one it's that simple
your co-workers
when you tell them that this is the
absolute this is
god playing with itself this is all god
playing with itself
this is all the absolute experiencing
itself
when you communicate that to people
they'll get it
many people will get it because it's
that
simple right now if you try
and get them to understand that they are
the source of awareness and realities or
to teach them how to netti nettie to
source the second and third divine toy
it's a little bit less likely
that those will land a lot less likely
but over time
more and more people will become
interested in mysticism
in yoga in
union with the absolute in
shifting their identity from the
contracted personhood
towards being god towards being the very
source of awareness and realities and so
that's the second divine
toy is reflect and meditate on you
being the very source the very emptiness
of awareness and of
infinite creation infinite creation
arising and passing
in your awareness infinite creation
arising and passing in your awareness
infinite creation arising and passing in
your awareness
and that is on the event horizon
of the source of the emptiness it is the
very
sourceful emptiness awareness
no self that is the very witness
observer of the infinite creation we
create
the witnessing of infinite creation
i am that which creates
the witnessing of infinite creation
i am that which creates the witnessing
of infinite creation
i am that which creates the witnessing
of infinite creation
i am that which creates the witnessing
of infinite creation
i make awareness and realities
i am that which creates the witnessing
of infinite creation
i make awareness and realities cool
so that's the second divine toy and the
third divine toy is the netty netty to
source so you practice
negating we have a video on our channel
called nettie nettie meditation
where i go through a process of an
hour-long slow-paced
guided meditation
of the neti neti that then
enables you to commune with your truest
nature
the most unchanging
it's the only true real
is that which does not change the very
emptiness does not change
the very source does not change
the very awareness itself does not
change
the only thing that changes is all of
the
impermanent infinite creation
so watch that video on the channel the
netty netty meditation
and leverage that as a divine toy to
move you
further from the person identity to
say that you're not the person identity
and you're not it's mind and body
and name and thoughts perception
sensations and you're not
even the awareness in which it happens
you are the very
source you are the very emptiness
that has awareness as the very first
attribute that
watches and witnesses infinite creation
leverage these three divine toys and you
will become
more and more of a gnostic
being you will become more actualized
you will
have experientially realized your true
nature in your heart many ways
and when you do that you
awaken and then you get to share
that awakening
you get to share freedom you get to
share bliss
you get to share peace you get to share
divinity
you become the absolute that you already
were
but you become it and when you become
the absolute when you recognize
yourself as the absolute you then become
a better steward a better
shepherd for the creation awakening
rather than being a contracted person
identity trying to
extract peace and happiness from it
so leverage these divine toys
in your meditations leverage them
in your day-to-day leverage them
as reflections
leverage them
and become more and more awake to your
true nature and share that
in awakening our creation
awesome and again
shout out to felix pannar that was a
great conversation between us on the
show
i highly recommend watching that
conversation as well
that's all infinite gratitude and unity
thank you
you